- Mike place the people I am
international arbiter my cover alongside
Tony Chan the most personal man in the
st. Louis chess club
that's what they say that's what they
say all right let's guess no further ado
let's get started yep and we will do all
rated games okay great it's not rated
I'm X in your house but any time control
you won so we have the link to play us
in our chat please click it rated games
only like Mike said not is it all the
time can you accept all time control
even even long ones they're the longest
I'll take is the intense chess format
that's one minute with a 10 second delay
yep so if you use all your time that
takes about what like 20 minutes okay so
we had the big intense just a $1000
$1000 national chess day and toads chose
invitational and it kicked off with
jonathan trots against adjourned
that took about 15 minutes to play and
they played like 71 moves no day okay
okay so it was kind of cool so if you
want to play so that's probably the
longest time control you can get from
for this show so you four and play
intense chess one minute gave me one
minute with 10 second delay try it out
if that's nobody usually nobody ever
really play plays a so I'll try it out
see if you like it we will probably do
intense chess against some sometime in
the future here so that's exciting
yeah it was a great matchup anyway on
Jonathan France defeated national master
Julian Pro LICO in the final round
they're always just drop the bishop he
just dropped up is he a GB you're
sucking right now dropping pieces
everywhere what's going on
oh but he's got Chuck he's got Chuck
it's good Chuck is all over the board
maybe I'll check me again maybe he'll
check me again to remove the check oh
okay okay is this gonna be checkmate
it could be it could be let's do it
let's do it Chuck Chuck Chuck do it do
it mate is there
oh my pawn is protected with my rook
yeah why would I take that why would I
intentionally play up that well he's
threatening to play that move don't dude
go go big or go home Mike go yeah take
it go big or go home
there you go boom boom boom alright so
viewers out there you probably can't
hear this but Danny would call calling
out Lucas from the back room so first
shout out to our man in the back Danny
Machuca who make this make this all
happen yeah and you know what it turned
into
yeah so we potentially some games today
could turn out to be Danny watch you go
plays the people over so we'll see how
it goes but uh it's a should be should
be a fun time show you have on time
oh here's comment pa TV give you a hand
for a good good try to try Plus a good
try so when we're doing this intense
just thing it's not a it's not an
increment because there's nothing uh
intense about increment yeah hey it's a
delay yeah no increments no oh except
for three if they play three - three -
that's a she was fine she's fine
typically no increments we're 32 is fine
longest time delay we can accept is
intense chess time control which is one
minute ten seconds for those of you
joining us try it out I actually never
tried it so it sounds sounds fun but
typically if you want to do like 5:03 -
that's the typical time control we
usually accept so try those rated games
only if you challenge us to a casual
game you will not be accepted right so
rated games only I'll say that pretty
much throughout the entire show so
everybody knows excuse no but definitely
no excuses for this one let's see who
you're playing is a
21:01 put them back into the 2000s put
them back into the 2011 Teen okay
eleventeen so we're trying to yeah we're
we're just shy of 2,000 trying to get
above that so Mike will probably try to
get that good there today while he's in
the middle game in that of that match
let's talk about what's happening here
at the st. Louis chess club so in the
next couple of days Saturday Sunday we
have a couple quick rated tournaments
going on
so tomorrow Saturday the 19th we have
Saturday night special and Sunday the
20th we have Sunday six players Swiss
two regular tournaments that happen all
the time here we usually get a pretty
good audience and pretty good player
pool so if you're ever if you're in town
try it out it should be fun and we do
have something happening tonight at 6:00
p.m. good old st. Louis master lab yeah
what do you know tell us about that Mike
what do I know about it what do I know
I'll be the it's a B they rated a
tournament five round six players and
Julian Pro League Oh a national master
you should everybody should try to come
here and beat him three intense chest
Jonathan Strong's club manager actually
defeated our national master Julian so
that was pretty pretty exciting well it
looks like you're are you when you
undecided some stuff going we got some
stuff I got yeah Mike's got some stuff
going it looks like he's slightly down
on time but that's okay that's okay he's
got quick hands he's got the lightning
blinding hands yeah I like it I like it
well see that comeback is on I don't
know why I put myself in this
predicament but I doubt that that pens
gonna
well opinion to win it and our opponents
doing it so good job on that so here's
here's a special deal for all our
viewers out there so we have so
Thanksgiving is net next month a little
over a month away we have the
Thanksgiving open which is one of our
biggest tournaments of the year here
please come check it out and then a
couple weeks before that on November 2nd
we have $5 thanksgiving open satellite
tournament so if you win all three of
your games you get free entry is that
what the deal is
it goes through Armageddon match yeah
okay so you have to win the Armageddon
if you go if two people go three and oh
gosh oh gosh
so whoever so it went have a chance to
win free entry into the Thanksgiving
open and which is actually the entry fee
is like 100 bucks
by that Saturday of the same day you
know if you don't then if you register
by November 22nd it's $100 but and then
after that it's the regular entry fee
which is one hundred and ten dollars so
you can save some money if you
pre-register ahead of time and I'll tell
you what I'll throw this out there for
all the viewers only for you are you
YouTube viewers if you guys pre-register
by November 2nd which is $80 mark we
will also throw in a price for you for
the first let's say first 10 people that
pre-register by that day we'll have some
prizes for you alright so if you only so
only for you guys if you want to
pre-register for Thanksgiving open
before on where before November 2nd
first 10 people you will get a prize see
Tony check see see Tony turn about that
I would have it set into place so you
can see everybody but we will first him
so on the day of the Thanksgiving open
on the data tournament I would have a
list of whoever the top for a first time
registering before November 2nd and will
give you give out prizes all right if
you say so
happening so I already already have it I
already have a set out I have a set out
so we're all good so I will I will
personally be here on Thanksgiving open
day just to hand those out to people all
right let's see here and just for the
record Thanksgiving open is not played
on the actual Thanksgiving correct
correct correct yes correct so it is
November 29th which is a Friday that's
that's basically round one starts and
then you have and goes until Sunday
December first yeah
all right where's that five five round
six round six six round Swiss game 90
plus thirty second increment three
sections we have open section under 18
hundred and under under 1,400 open
section is feed a rated so if you want
to gain some feed a rating that's that's
the place to go alright so that's that's
our tournament schedule for the next for
this month and night next month so
please come if you're not in town coming
in town play if you are in town there's
no reason why you shouldn't be here you
still playing the same person oh so you
will give you a hand good good job 2100
good job will you're playing Tonya Tonya
playing Tonya right now 18 you brought
the same skill yeah we want to we were
we are 41 points away from reaching two
thousand so we're definitely trying to
reach out go today how you doing this
game you're doing anything pretty good
undecided beside his rooks are so Danny
Machuca if you wanna y'all saw some
moves do it man do it
nice got this one he's got confidence in
me I don't believe somebody said a world
chess I go might go oh
it's gonna be it's gonna be just like
that uh truck berries on goji ani go go
my go go go go Mike go go go come on why
not
why not what a horrible move late play
bold play bold man it was play bold yeah
oh we got my Paul and he got my boy
I really wanted that poem to I really
got a check
[Music]
all right so we talked about what
happened what's going to happen here the
same in the Chess Club but let's talk
about what's happening chess
internationally and and Nanette
nationally if we want to talk about that
but as you know I oh man tournament is
happening right now
so after let's see here after round
seven it looks like two people are tying
tied for first one is Levon Aronian the
other is our very own American Fabiano
Khurana so that is exciting so hopefully
if so though hopefully they'll keep that
up folks with Fabio they'll keep that up
throughout the tournament and he'll hold
he'll finish first
Fabiana already has a spot in the can in
this tournament all right so yeah so we
so even if you win so it'll go to
somebody else let's see who else is
worth mentioning
what's Wesley so how is Wesley Wesley so
he is he has four and a half points so
it's a point behind the number at number
1 and right now he is tied for 10th with
four and a half points with like 15
people so he still has a chance to go up
top as assuming like you know LaVon
doesn't doesn't do as well we're
Colorado doesn't do as well he has a
chance to go to number one so fingers
crossed we're have fingers crossed for
all the American players out there most
importantly the arch the Archbishop's
the Archbishop Archbishop's it's got a
new player for next year mr. linear
domain newly newly joining the US
Federation linear so we're happy about
that we want to encourage all the top
players to just switch Federation's this
come over to the US coming to the u.s. I
mean we have we have the st. Louis Chess
Club so that's pretty much all you need
just come over here come over here we
welcome everybody but mainly the top
layers
well the fact we're on the top layers to
come here
all right Tanya how are you doing here
it looks like okay Tanya slightly ahead
slightly ahead dude oh my god I could
have had it all could I had it all you
got lucky there Tanya you got lucky you
got lucky you're up by 10 seconds Mike
come on come on Mike let's do it I'm so
mad mad at you for dropping that I can't
believe either that should punish
yourself for that one punished let's get
some let's get some pieces going let's
get some pieces going yeah drive that
Bishop out of there tried that Bishop
out of there
huh guy said I was hoping the mystery
man was going to join the archbishop's
there's other time while you are you the
mystery man there he supposed to join
artichokes Danny Machuca that thumb that
thumbnail you put up his awesome you saw
that right
somebody set that so great great he
likes to somebody likes to intense chest
format that was really enjoyable so
we'll definitely do that in the future
for sure I'm still waiting for somebody
to write write us on your info we're
saying with Jessica or somebody supposed
to give me some stuff to take to the
boss you know come on
there is the email links info as st.
Louis chess club org email us let us let
us know how we're doing give us
suggestions for any future shows you
want to see if they're saying it shows
that we already had on that you
particularly light right write us and
we'll probably do more of that all right
all right now we're wait did you want
win against Tonya no I lost Oh Tonya
hands good hand hand to you Tonya a good
job good job good job
all right now you're playing against mag
Han 98 okay it's ready a 13 20 dude are
you are you just picking like a lower
rated players to play now you wait you
went from like over to 2100 to 1800 now
you're 1,300 I just click whatever I can
click and this is not a game for the
ages either black did not trust that
Bishop sack by Mike nope Queeny to check
it was gonna devastate them yeah alright
let's talk about are you do you are you
still only playing um what are the CCC
five against everything we're playing
yes okay so viewers if you are playing
white Mike is playing c5 as black
against anything so try out b4 see how
that takes you you see where that takes
you okay hopefully that'll work and well
it's not good for us because we want to
gain some points but you know trying to
help you guys out and help you guys out
I'm curious of how many viewers out
there how many of you are actually in
st. Louis or actually in the US I want
to I'm curious are you guys majority
overseas because if you're that's what
it seems like we have a lot of people
chatting us from the Europe channels
from South America Asia
so that's let us know where you're from
I'm curious for those of you who are
outside the US let's let's I'm gonna
talk about some US related items to let
you know what's going on here
okay did you guys know that California
or is having a lot of earthquakes late
lately
alright and it's causing a major
faultline for the first time so that's
my member first time ever that's what
that's what according to the CN SNC CNN
that's what a study shows the San
Francisco earthquake during the the
Dodgers are know that they I'm sorry
they're not the doctors the San
Francisco Giants and the Oakland A's
they had to postpone the World Series
because of it see that he Mike knows
that fact not just because he loves
sports but because he's old enough to
remember that one yep yeah so and we
just said that Mike's a big sports fan
what do you think about let me you know
how
lat less like this year like the big
hype is Zion Williamson
you know like how he supposed to be what
do you do you think do you agree with
that
so yeah you never ever won two
especially if you're like this big
superstar right he's a freshman coming
out of him out of Duke or whatever blew
out is yeah blew out his uh his knee
went that when his shoe went wrong but
yeah you never want to peek in the
preseason I mean it's like absurd so
he's he's hurt again right he's hurt now
he can't be hurt yet but now he's put up
like record numbers but it's the pre C
yeah nobody cares about that
yeah that's silly so my team is Michael
Porter Jr and the Denver Nuggets on the
on the west coast East Coast side I'm on
I'm all over the Pacers this year so
those are my two tickets hey Sara's okay
okay alright
their superstar is hurt right now but
but once they get that's what you want
to hear that's what you want to hear
superstar and they did the best strategy
ever they got the Rookie of the Year
from the number one team from the east
from the Milwaukee Bucks Malcolm Brogdon
so they got they got the number one like
their opposition the number one guys
main man that's calling all the plays so
now he'll come over and help beat the
Bucks so so you're saying so you're
saying giannis is not gonna come on come
on
I mean yeah probably not but we're
talking off basketball three seasons
going regulars yeah regular seasons
about to start it's gonna be exciting
didn't it uh I just let's see here we
have some years uh oh you're from the
Netherlands okay okay that's cool
awesome yeah
we have a gentleman from in India all
right Rolla Missouri hey you're only
you're like four three hours away
see yes most people probably don't know
this about Rolla Missouri but they have
a beach there no they don't it's in the
how do you have a visa it's like
man-made down there like literally in
the middle of the country Yama Beach is
that come on the beach all right all
right I know how they did it but there's
a beach down there so and you know props
to ya I never I never knew that that's
that's cool that's cool
Cabo USA okay oh the guy from the
Netherlands actually just got back from
teaching chest kiss chest that's awesome
we have a giant scholastic program here
we teach a lot of kids so props to you I
know they can be a handful so the guy
from the Netherlands saying he's
impressed with the athlete from the US
named Simone biles and her jumps are on
another level okay you know what that is
big Simone biles yeah she's uh which
we'll call it gymnast yeah yeah for the
US yeah actually what's funny about her
is uh like they have chumps named after
her like oh here comes some old piles
doing the trials because she does moves
out of this world so but I prefer the
lady from UCLA we have a gentleman from
New Zealand
oh so the guy from Rolla did come
confirm that there is an article of
artificial Beach I'll give you a hand to
that I mean like I'll writing them in
Rolla I don't there's our physical Beach
that's awesome I like it I like it
some person wants to know when our
viewers wants to know will D we're there
will there be another or more beginner
breakdown lectures from Mike way is he
asking because he doesn't want it
clogged up that are clogging up the
YouTube channel or cuz he's it cuz they
once it I think I think he wants it with
Jean you want to clarify some more you
will want it where do you not want it
will answer your questions after that
kiona nice is that at the actual
colonies from st. st. Louis here he says
he knows the USC oh the UCLA gymnast
cousin awesome alright alright cool
Kyle if that's the real Kyle Nia so
that's the real colonists from st. Louis
oh wow why don't I ever see you here
anymore what's up with that what's up
with that is a working man he's a
working man he is he is and a married
man right oh yes true but true dad that
does take time away all right oh he says
he wants to begin her Britt breakdown so
you gonna do more maybe I'll think about
it
but no guarantees no no guarantees well
you heard it well think about it which
in in in it will fit in this country
basically means mate probably not so but
fingers crossed fingers crossed
oh it is the actual colonies and yes
marry life well give a shout-out to our
friendly neighbor Kyle nice hopefully
we'll see you more hopefully we'll see
you at the things team you open big
tournament yeah and just to reiterate
from earlier if you pre-register by
November 2nd is cheaper and the first
ten people to pre-register by then will
give you a prize all right they'll heat
that one viewer says he loves the mic
videos although not although not as
accurate in the analysis as a GM but
it's also very energetic and Anna
training day that's a that's a pro and
con at the same time bring you up or you
down yeah it's like that's cool love it
love it but I I agree with this
assessment okay how could I as you can
clearly see did you win that like I did
well right hands good good try for the
was a 13-8 8000 good try good try try
not dirty flag dirty that's book hot hey
you should have try to check make me
dude it's like you can't just sit there
all day so when is a win that's right it
doesn't matter if you ever played any
sports you you know and when is a win it
doesn't matter how you get it that's
right for you
all right now we're playing a 2000 okay
hopefully we'll gain some points come on
Mike my my doctor the good doctor
so so here's a fun fun fact
well not fun fact like it's going on on
Newton OU's now all the time you know
how like a a group of celebrities is
paying for their children to be at a
great school even though they didn't
make it there on merit we won't go into
all the names and stuff but you know
that that happens that's I feel like I
feel like that happens in every major
every pretty much every country every
state every city province whatever you
want to call it like if you have the
money to guarantee your children into a
great school even they didn't deserve to
get in and why wouldn't you do that
would you I mean what do you think like
if you know there's a there's a front
door to get in there's a back door to
get in there's always different ways to
get in and like if you have the means to
do it I don't I don't see like yes it's
unethical but it happens everywhere like
if it just so happens that this one
group got caught and they're like making
the example out of them so they're like
harsh punishments even some jail time
but it's it happens every day I why to
Mia and let's just be honest here if I
had if I kids I don't if I had kids and
if I had the means to get him into a
school that they didn't get in by
themselves I would do it I would do it
Danny thoughts that was a no comment so
we are
man you know I'm I'm I'm gonna I put it
out there I can't like it is
alright that's real life real life I
mean if you donate a bunch of money to
get into uh you know put for a new
library your kids gonna get the go there
you know so what's the difference yeah
and but as I said I don't have any kids
either and Netherlands um yep
I'm calling like I see it bro alright
money does buy success fact of life back
to life right you know you know how they
say money makes money it stems from from
that fact right so apparently it doesn't
happen in Germany because education is
there is free I I bet you I bet you
there's still something like that going
on alright tutoring a mean thing all
right Kiki geez is that how you
pronounce name key juice are you gonna
challenge this to a game I wanna I want
to see you I want to see you play Mike
and then I'm gonna trash talk the entire
time even though we're friends you're
friends of the show so but still we're
still gonna trash talk the king of the
Netherlands was bad in school is that
your that's really funny we've got a
nice degree yeah yeah Mike's talking to
himself about the game which means he's
in trouble he's in trouble
do your down on time but I love plus oh
here we go
you gotta move faster man oh I got two
minutes I cut to me that's like an
eternity for me your opponent asked over
three minutes that's even like if if he
gets you into a position of the other
thing allow you it's over
come on dude I created intense chest
with the winner of intense chest Nick
Jonathan shrugs I trust me okay
I know how to barge in my time just
because he created intense Chad's he's
stating these basically I just saying
he's he's got it all right so we'll see
we'll see yeah I never want to move that
rook I never want to move that rook up
all right dr. mock Moktar motor you're
playing Mike and Daniel yet he's just
yelling out moves now let's do it let's
do it
GG's DG's challenges I'll go
Gigi switch your name on on life chess
so we can try to find you
I sure we remember this by now because I
remember talking to you four previous
shows but you know bad bad memory that's
why I don't play chess a lot something
in front of me is that a winning move
that's a winning move here we go up dr.
Walter that's a winning move that means
you okay here we go
but when I got a check coming up to just
the just a really good so you're down on
material yeah well he's down material
you're down you got it come on man let's
do it
I've got a bishop he's got a bunch of
Paul yeah that's cool that's cool that's
cool cool
all right so giggy's is the same same
name on each as he challenged a while
ago I mean we try to play him see how he
does is gij s I kid so Magnus hands
first said I can't believe I missed that
dish up in the game earlier I could
believe it we can believe it we can
believe that Mike's pretty intimidating
especially especially over the Internet
well you can't see him somehow he's
intimidating yeah how embarrassed that's
how embarrassing c'est la vie man it
happens it happens
oh you just don't your rug doctor
mockery selling your rook on the road -
mm we are officially on the road - yeah
we go Kiki jeez yeah geez you're up
let's see how you do
let's see how I do here comes the
trash-talking you saw cuz he pre pre
moves c5 no matter oh I want to see
somebody I want to see somebody play BB
for as white and just I have and just
see if you can play outplay us Mike c5
dr. Z wants to play you only HS okay
we'll try to get to you we'll try to get
to make sure all the new viewers who are
just starting to check out the channel
probably play radio games only so no
casuals radio games only we're trying to
do bliss time control the the longest
time control will take is intense chest
time control which is game 1 minute 10
second delay if you use already time
takes about 20 minutes okay so that's
the longest DJ's we just took your pong
for free what's up what's up in the
words of Maurice Ashley that move was
like I'm gonna sit on your face that's a
direct quote by the way I saw down on
one of those I was like wow that's a
that's a pretty bold statement but I'm
gonna I'm gonna try and try it one day
so there it is there it is dr. motor
says good game our friend Danny Machuca
in the back put up the link to challenge
us on light chess so do click that link
radio game alright see for why in the
world would he play is that just another
free pawn is that a free pawn Kiki Jesus
looks like you're good about to give it
up again give it up take it Mike
boom take it Oh what is like right next
to it you're like I didn't see it come
on kind of excuses that
it's like here is it's like you're
driving on the road right next somebody
is like you crashing them as I didn't
see you
what's up what come on come on really
want to checkmate this guy on g2 that's
cool
you heard it you heard it Gigi's our
goal is to checkmate you on cheat it's
happening it's happening I dare you to
move your knight on f3 I dare you to
move that except uh yeah do it I don't
like this guy's gives you to down some
pawns you still want to you still want
to trade we still trying to trade there
we're taking it
we're taking it
let's go Mike can't write pride is on
the line for this one you can't lose
this I don't even need to meet you g2
anymore
you heard it we don't care about g2
anymore we're still gonna meet you
though you know it's gonna happen
oh he's training everything off gang
okay Gigi's bold plan I don't know I
don't know what you plan is but it looks
both so far so props to you just based
on that fact today looks like you're in
a winning position almost like we're
about to win yeah I mean Gigi just
slightly up on time but I don't see that
being a factor I I think Mike's in the
to take this one I think mines gonna
take this one I'm gonna pre call it
right now pre college yeah with that to
second increment yeah it's almost too
easy there you go there you go now we if
you want double few rocks will do it too
right that's the deal that's the deal
don't don't
kind of play this game based on logic
what's the best lot logic be a Vulcan I
need you to be a Vulcan pure logic a
hundred percent know you motion added oh
okay eighty-five we're gonna call call
that I in accuracy in accuracy oh oh
here we go
not a five yet tackle a tactics master
tactics
sometimes it's the second move of the
variation it's like you can do just like
oh it looks like it looks like some
somebody just said Michael blow it oh oh
wow calling Mike out Wow okay alright so
did ya take a look and don't take it
back smart man smart
Fiji's see this this is aiming at you
this hand just hit headshake right here
and that's a I'm up a punch down up a
touchdown plus I'm gonna pull out you
can be matumbo and go like this to like
that oh I could just oh I don't know oh
you do that oh this is gonna hurt this
is gonna hurt oh yeah there will be no
yeah dang alright well for just to
clarify for all you know who do not know
who Dikembe Mutombo is he is a former
basketball player yeah tre trademark
thing was going like this
uh-uh not in my house after he blocks
since I saw somebody so that yeah that's
that's where it's coming from didn't
turn back spanker threats it's like
you're only you're only a pro here is
your up on time but that's not it's not
me that's not yeah two seconds it's not
a factor anymore so you're you're about
to get you're about to get mated let's
do this Mike let's do this
No zero inaccuracies blow boom out blow
them out
finish this game perfectly
think think think of this game as like
you're at your astronaut in space one
low in accuracy calculation it's gonna
cost your life alright that's that
supposed to wear how we're playing out
Danny I'm gonna hurt I haven't hurt you
because there's nothing to say they're
ready talking about yeah take it take it
pawn for a pawn we don't care about that
do it give megive me a check there you
go boom
Miley chess ID is Madhava Mata and 3004
oh I remember you from the other time
okay well try to get to you there is no
list because mice is gonna pick whoever
he wants to pick so we'll try to get
good to you no promises cuz we basically
only have like 45 minutes left
alright so that's that's basically like
five mmo's five more games so fingers
crossed I board games is that right
well depends on one time for show this
but I'm just gonna guess it's close to
five gaming like five zero that's how
you you know I'm still predicting
hanging a piece in time pressure
oh he's pretend you're gonna hang a
piece dang wow I never I never knew he
was gonna call you out like it like that
alright here we go here we go time
pressure no no mistakes Mike no mistakes
and we're gonna call this officially
over because you think I mean a rook and
three pawns versus a 1-1 pawn here it's
over it's over block him off aw come on
mister two squares block him off there
we go and you are stuck house this is
like you're being stuck in trips
oh you're in quicksand keep it out boom
giggy's hands up good try good try good
try good try good try and for all the
people that said that the mic is gonna
blow it you suck you suck I wouldn't go
that go it I'll call it out yep you're
gonna play BB for lost net so you can
play against e5 what's my wasp neck
you're up yeah before the first before I
seen all day oh let's see how you gonna
do this great ratings about this day
Danny Machuca you were late on your you
supposed to give us advice on that one
man he Jie said he got intimidated by us
games and he says well played well
played good great sportsmanship great
sports great sportsmanship yeah we love
seeing great so so so of the first
person that played before is giving a
mic putting Mike on the ropes right now
dang not really not really I am NOT on
the ropes I am oh okay okay all right
all right
somebody said f6 suspicious is it though
is it though
nice opening mic oh oh oh
wasps nests wow that's a huge blunder
their day Wow Wow after dang I thought
you had it too but I'm you saying you
still might have it so might have it but
it's tough now intense time time
pressure here tennis time pressure oh my
god okay good job watching that's good
job good job
a little yeah who you playing doc doc
dr. Zee's been on for Saturday here we
go
Savage Dragon you're on to get some
points we're both on the road of 2000
where are 30 points that way so that's
pretty okay Kyle nice asses there squats
tonight
yes there is Kyle come on up come on up
both heads gambit watch out Mike all
right we need 30 points Savage Dragon
needs 75 to reach 2,000 will ya we'll
see who gets there first it's a race to
race wits where it's only name only
anime boom I love it ah all right that
was good that was good
we'll take that take it in stride
are you playing a savage dragon looks
like he is yeah that's equal do you
always play c4 as white is that we is
that what you did this game I knew I
wasn't paying attention is what it is no
I don't never play c4 okay okay d4 don't
take the pole
deal got it got it yeah junior Matt says
good game yeah good job good job
my King falls man easy points for you
easy easy points for us is that true
we're not gonna we're not gonna sir if
that's true or not but we challenge us
on a radio game we'll see if we get to
you okay
joonie matt is up for a game yeah we'll
try to get to you as soon as we can if
you're if you're you YouTube name is not
the same as your leach s name typo sir
your chest name - so when so we know to
look out for you okay
all right all right we might have a
bishop of opposite color ending coming
up oh okay okay but I'm not afraid of it
I'm not afraid I'm not afraid
interesting game love to see how where
he goes love to see how way he goes
we got the c7 squirt of it up Mike did
we hear about this Oh is there a check
check waiting thing going Oh almost you
don't want to move your uh yeah it's
gonna say you want to try out something
like that it's a trick
give the man double pause give the man
it looks like dr. moukhtar asks if you
are down for another game so we
typically do not try to play same people
in the same day just because we want to
give more people more chances of other
people we want as many people to play as
possible
my king falls Ismaili chest name been on
four bits my King falls we will try to
get to you bro all right we'll try all
like always no guarantees but we will
try are you doing moving up WI solid
solid play solid play always tried
doubling up for you looks so sick that's
a pretty sick move right there okay I
love it Bishop Bishop I'll be show okay
looks you're up slight yeah Savage
Dragon that's tight that this is a tight
game it's not really a tight game you
might look like it's a tight game but as
any chess expert knows oh sorry I let me
clarify when I first you know when I
when I said tie game I don't mean like
close game I mean like that's tight this
is a positional masterpiece right sep 2
roots on the seventh rank what else can
you ask for right all right move the
take
you might even want to just resign in
this position it's just so we won't yeah
we will always look at that reservations
oh okay
take your pawn and now now you're just
now your it's officially over I probably
have made an eleven I'm gonna think it's
already pre-calculated meaning 11 just
just hit the hit the way yeah this game
is not going to move 35 Darren hit hit
the resign button you see that there's a
flag is that one of those yeah he hit
the resign button right now savage come
on man
now I just need to check pain pain to
victory on lately Ches says play please
play me we'll try to get to you no
promises as we only about just a little
over half an hour left on the show we'll
probably get to play about three maybe
four games more okay so we'll see how
are you gonna stop this checkmate that's
the real question
boom bite check you got a spy Chuck
you're gonna spike he's gonna stop and
then this guy in the other spy chick so
that adds up to two more moves
where is he gonna just be like be be a
gentleman just hit the resonation button
just be a gentleman man we always we
always tell the kids that we teach here
to not give up play to the end but you
know what in this case just just hit hit
the resign button hit the resign button
this is easy just go like this
it's done you down down and position it
down on time what else come on Plus 316
anyways so you're up let's let's talk so
you know so I was watching ESPN this
morning and I was also watching the game
on Thursday with up with the Chiefs and
you know how Patrick mahomes got hurt
one of the one of the highly viewed
quarterbacks got hurts oh is this
checkmate it's coming Jagan good try you
did not make it the rule 35 have a
dragon good try thank you for giving us
6 points now we are only 24 points wait
and we have over 24 so might so doc dr.
Zee's been winning for a while my king
falls me waiting you're up oh you only
Tommy and may have more count so every
point counts even if it's a millimeter
pointer whatever every point counts
we need after challenge for a while now
we'll get to you
Kelly turn around we'll get to you oh
well no no promises we'll try to get to
you let's do it let's do it
do you play see if I even play c5 again
yeah of course so you guys I don't know
if you guys saw the game when somebody
played b4 just to mike c c5 that that
game they won that game so you might
want to try try that when you're playing
white play play b4 all right let's see
Gigi says Mike big brain 200 comer
strikes again
do you ever play the one wandering King
that's that's Danny Machuca sting
against weaker players where he when
he's playing why here okay not my king
well so it's like basically when you're
playing Wyatt you you play f3 and then
you move move your king to F - that's a
180 to move against weaker players see
how long evening and if you can
basically defend against all the attacks
and win I mean I mean so obviously
you're not gonna cancel at this point
we're gonna do a little king let's see a
king knife 7 that were you gonna do
there's nothing I really can do and here
we go more advice from D Machuca yeah we
can we can agree to a draw Bishop b2
Knight of 6 that's funny
alright they did not want to go there he
didn't know well maybe didn't want to go
there I junior Mac I'm the comeback kid
so I really don't care
q you're Matt if you challenge us on
lately chest we it will it will be
showing on our side honor and it's just
we have a long list and we're not going
to get through everybody so we'll know
like we always say no guarantees but
we'll try to get to you we I mean we are
doing this almost every single weekday
so if you want to play us you can try on
other days we can't get it today okay
oh I just lost my knight alright I was
Bank anyone see it I was beauty is just
killing you good job dr. Z good job
feeding master is uh mr. Han smoke
Neiman texting me some uh some move so
we're saying how bad on play one of the
other but world champion on smokin even
over a chance
Louis there we go Annie let's just
assume that he's making fun of you let's
just assume that all right here comes
the moment of truth here comes the
moment of truth we're gonna explode and
I'm winning we got a pen going okay
pretty not gonna fall for that dr. Z is
your rate rating and reading only 1182
that's seen it's a really low for how
your how well you're doing against Mike
here stop it if you would see the amount
of bread on both sides of this game it
would astound it's basically I'm playing
like an eleven eighty two when he's
playing like an 11
Wow so basically he doesn't want to give
you any compliments he's basically I'm
playing down to you dang dang you stop
dr. Zee's just crush him in this game
and start Matt trash-talking on the chat
and playing super are you just trying to
win on time now no is this is there any
increment no increment so you could win
on time alright still theory
you know what you can have you can have
a pawn grabbing all right
I should have just gone to g1 in the
first yeah why didn't you dang
so when somebody says I don't want to
talk about it it just basically means I
made a mistake I don't want to I don't
want people to know about it yeah big
mistake he should have played rook to
wherever
just because a lot of people do
something doesn't make it okay I totally
agree with that
what is that referring to haven't seen a
st. Louis chest video and a winner while
whose fault is that I was gonna say like
why you just you should be just smacking
yourself we could for that one
you should always be watching our videos
viewers we have a pleasant surprise for
you
we have been Simon just who just walked
on the set you might see him as a
commentator for various tournaments but
he's coming here you might he wants to
say hi penny why don't you come back and
say hi to everybody
you're gonna play my miking Falls hiking
balls up there right there oh there you
go
miking Falls you're up have a seat
ladies and gentlemen here is Ben Simon
and we and we're getting in a hand we're
getting a hand clap from Danny Machuca
in the bag which means you all which now
you should know he's very good at what
he does as a commentator you so fun
facts Ben Simon is actually a
commentator for wrestling is that what's
the league yeah there's actually a
couple of companies there's no World
League wrestling & Glory Pro you know
actually I just came in here to close
the door though there's a kid in the
other room oh okay so concerned it
looked like with comer screaming the
door is still not closed which means my
coming you're being too loud that's what
you say louder louder louder louder here
we go
louder so what's the record been like
today good we're on the road - mm we're
on there we've been on the road mm for a
while now um don't uh
I'm kicking myself I still made Jonathan
in the last game oh my name I am
Oliveira Lucas if we can play - I'm
kicking myself after a stalemate
Jonathan in the last game will try to
get to you no promises kiichi said Mike
escaped from that last game huh alright
there was never any doubt never any
doubt is there a resident GM at the club
at the moment yes there is always a
resident GM here at all times
right now it is still Grandmaster peg
cuenca but that's about to change next
week I think Oh grand mr. Jesse cried
Jesse cries coming in yeah Jesse cars
are great if you ever seen a video say
he does first he's a great teacher great
with everybody fun guy so join us when
he's here you know one of the Oh and he
has a book
Danny Danny my choucas pointing out he's
an author as well yeah where is it Lee
Lisa it's a novel Lisa oh he oh just not
tres book but a novel check it check it
out it's a novel about chess God you
guys are killing me out of here
all right iam a mop since he's Cynthia
five five zero three two doesn't matter
all right one of those is fine and you
wanted to pretty has to be a rated game
we're not even guaranteeing we're gonna
get get to you because there's only
about 25 minutes left cheers from Brazil
Brazil guys from Mozilla good to see you
on here Pepe is very high-energy yeah he
is yeah he is that's why we love him
that's why we love ya he did a great job
at the $1,000 national chest day yeah
intense chess invitational which Ben
Simon missed because he was announcing
wrestling even if it was national chess
day it's like forget it I'm going to do
my wrestling thing comer you have
connections you could probably have them
rescheduled the entire national chess
day right why didn't you do that that's
a good question
that's a good question why don't you use
your connection I gave him three months
notice man man
well I'll tell you what not only is Pepe
really good in that commentary role but
last night he actually set an all-time
lecture viewership record
hmm I don't have what that number was
yet because the video is not done
processing but the first lecture he did
at 6:30 on facing the London system beat
Yasser Sarah wons record from oh four
years ago he was that's impressive yeah
that's impressive so people love Pepe
give a hand to give a hand to pepper
so some gentleman said Jesse cry has
quality wrestling announcing a bilious
as well is that true okay is that a joke
are you playing with me what is that
about come on Jesse brings it up a lot
though nezzie okay all right Imam 200
yes you are on the list however we have
a long list so no guarantees we'll try
we'll try okay Gigi says very nice I'm
assuming it's about your play but I
don't trust it because your place not
that great Yassir is amazing -
impressive Pepe out did it we are very
impressed we're always trying to find
somebody that's you know go one one step
above so good almost almost seven on
wire there that's okay how are you doing
Mike it looks like you're losing mm-hmm
what kind of confidence can an opponent
have with a name like Mike King Falls
you're you're 38 seconds left I'm
guessing it's uh
what he first started playing that's
what happens a lot so that's why he's
this name thing you can't ever change
your day can you on me Chaz I'm sure you
can
maybe maybe you start at another account
that's cool I like when Danny knows the
answers to our questions that are kind
of rhetorical and he mutters them in the
next room and you can kind of hear him
but you're like yeah I still know what
he said I oh oh queen sack okay I'm just
assuming I'm just assuming that he's
gonna play badly and lose so how you
were watching yeah I like sorry viewers
I always I always want to advise the
inning to put on a mic so you can hear
we
but he never does you know what how you
pranic he asked Holly katana might come
out out here join us for a little minute
we have I will give you I'll give you my
mic I'll give you my mic come on come
and come out here and say hi somebody
that gotta be back there I don't know if
that's sure or not not not all times
not all times so you guys are playing
the caveman chest where there's no
increment in no delay right no why are
you so against that I don't get it why
are you so again against no no delay we
increment when it comes to this well let
me just clock you out when I'm losing
okay I win what's the yeah that's a
strategy that's silly it's a strategy
need to have an increment or delay
intelligent blitz but the point is moot
because comer says he's playing with the
increment to second increment let's see
if he sees it oh no check arou check a
ruski check it risky down on time man
down on time my king falls you got you
can't can't wait any more pre-move pre
move it doesn't matter if it's bad pre
move 10 seconds versus a minute dude
you're gonna lose my King falls is yeah
I mean you can't just [ __ ] this guy out
and that's true
but that's a viable strategy Ben don't
don't knock it don't knock it
you know I was actually just playing
Nick risco outside beautiful day and he
waited to play the smashing combination
against me to destroy me until he had
like one second left on the clock and
you can do that when you have increment
yes my type of time control right here
oh my god oh yeah Tuesday he beat me
let's see here so he looks like somebody
made fun of Mike and then key and then
key jeez is defending you he says have
some faith in Mike he crushed me in that
in that one game if you call him bad
what do you think of all the players I
lost to him are thank you kgs
Mike's think Mike thanks you
Mike thanks you I I don't cuz I'm not
really cheering for anybody I'm just
making fun of people let's do it
let's do it come on f6 f6 for the win
are you doing it sucks so close so close
good job getting out of there I guess
really close nice try my king of all
it's nice try
give me a hand for that one good try
good try that's why you never give up
never surrender Mike seems to say I've
gotten a lot stronger over the last
couple of years has has therap in a feed
a rate remaining change is there maybe
not feed it right at us CF 1800 are you
are you passed out yet I'm like 1760
1760 okay
I was once 1800 wasn't able to stop you
before you started this next game but
how about some raided horde chess
what's whatever that is what is that
it's where you have like a million pawns
versus no regular guys no chess of the
future I'm telling you no come on
hence come on that's the raid of the
future all right what funny thing about
intense chess is the USCF will not rate
intense chest was gonna get a bundle
employee but no I guess not no I guess
not
you know it could be rated by the
universal rating system coming really
yeah surely gaming in at 11 Wow okay
viewers said good view beautiful maiden
that last game Mike I agree that was a
beautiful mate walking into that one my
king flawless walk in that one yeah all
right
Oh Bensimon has enough he is leaving
thank you very much for joining us sir
dun-dun-duh who are you playing against
all right we are at 1981 we are only 19
points away from reaching 2000 perfect
perfect you playing wait a minute no it
looks like you're playing a shock wave
who is 18:56 oh you can gain a lot of
points when this guy doing if I win why
because it's not a certainty Mike if
you're if you're trying to brag like yes
I'm definitely gonna win you know what
I'll join you on that one all right
let's go Mike let's go and ladies and
gentlemen we have another another
special guest here joining us we have
the assistant manager of the stainless
chess club Dennis the demon LaRue coming
in he's just dropping off his bags when
he's gonna join us in a minute so it's
gonna be fun all right the last player
says thanks for the game I'm gonna have
some games to get back to to 2100 again
tomorrow all right bring it on well
you're not giggy's bring it on
and here he is the man of the hour no
literally the actual no no he hasn't got
so - mm yeah he's not the man right now
we need to get in mm business I just saw
that amazing meeting I saw it all right
yes I thought there was a to Main and
11th I've calculated it out today
Jonathan never doubted you oh good let's
do it let's do it
I doubt it all right very so shocked
waving you down on time down on position
I'm just gonna say I'm gonna bet that
Mike place solidly what's the move
Oh Danny said did any much sugar in the
bags just said maybe nicéphore yeah shot
shockwave you're not playing against
Mike you're playing against three three
members of the Chess Club right now oh
my oh my he's dennis is being nice it's
I I'm a realistic guy I call it like it
is
hey whoo I would say about maybe like 90
percent Mike Timbers everybody else
all right this will get us some points
and we got 15 minutes to do this we have
the ghost of an a-class
Dennis so the GG said I hear that Dennis
trained using the eat like a grandmaster
method by Ben fine goal is that true
that's true
confirm confirmed also I'm supposed to
ask you about that illegal move oh yeah
what's that mean online competition I
participated I'm sure is there a legal
move yeah yeah I lost my I lost my game
against Google check by intention I
gotcha I gotcha yeah yeah yeah that was
a tactical blunder he was trying to
psyche fuga chef's out but it didn't
work so you know Mike viewers asked the
question is can Mike Queen sack again
are you trying to clean sack again
somewhere there's a nice sack nope no
idea I'm just making up stuff right now
Dennis you think a lot of coffee okay
that is oh that is written by one of our
local viewers is that is that Rex
where's that rep is that Rex's mom who's
talking boy who his little brother
boy oh it's the little little one of of
that family Roy okay who wit which one
it is a John is it let us know the one I
played breakfast before I think Roy is
now rated like right at a thousand so
which is pretty pretty good he's he's
come a long way in the past year so
props
yeah you know that guy that that like
loses in the most horrible embarrassing
fashion that's me yeah yep it happens
happens
c'est la vie so they you know I'm the
ghost of the 1900 is giggling in the
back too just so everybody knows Dennis
I'm curious how much coffee do you drink
a day on an average at least two two
gallons to a gallon say minimum nice
dough so if you don't drink coffee that
your hand go go like this okay Danny Wow
nice deep dependent on substance okay
let's see Mike is winning shock waves
rose shock wave you're you're losing
here shock wave give us some points
bring us a 2000 bring us to 2000 we have
about 13 minutes left so probably after
this game we have one more tip probably
one more game after that maybe two we'll
see b5x clam from someone oh oh well ah
bye Mike and then there we go peace
guess ya see ya what happens in a rated
tournament game if you had that reaction
we need we need to get 2,000 Mike get
you mm this is the chance
what's that say pain to Victor and he's
actually right now mm thing okay we're
15 points away we need it
15 points away yeah we should flip flop
ratings if I win that should be the deal
I get 15 you lose 50 let me just go in
and hack in interleave leech as I make
that happen I think we knew that could
happen
Oh Dennis LaRue yeah you've seen this
before huh you've seen this before
Dennis Danes calling you and why are you
talking like calling out yeah why you
hung around even though you know what
what I do you still one time
and I was like working the front desk
okay still no I don't know what he's
talking so there could be so there could
be two a lot logical reasons for this
one is micah is actually making some
random stuff up that didn't happen or
attendances of stuff to bears a saying
dennis is humorously actually made this
i think i think everybody knows it's
true yeah big o my cover beat me on to
his dreams was playing them from the
front desk while i was like checking
people into the club and working alright
i get a reprieve here i get a reprieve
whatever that so one of our viewers
asked what happens to Mike's hair are
you referring to
so super-strong yeah Danny Danny much
sugar in the back is there a way on the
stream you can make Mike like have an
energy glow around him yeah let's try to
do that let's try to do that I'd be cool
maybe you just have to yell like Goku
that's right that's right you should do
on jag amazi where they're like they
they go like were they like one fight
takes like 10 episodes we should be like
one game takes do you remember
I got I just got remember that one one R
we're a 56 watch maybe seven we just
came one thanks for tuning in you get
the Zeke last ten minutes of me trying
to get 2000 yeah it looks totally
coasting to tooth down so it looks like
we have time for one more game after
this one so we're happy about that so
we're so happy
well there's a lot you don't know mister
didn't know mm Raider players also draw
pieces yeah
humans drop pieces okay yeah if you're
not 2000 you're an amateur
powering up takes 10 episodes that's
probably yeah I remember that one fight
where like where they go to
Piccolo's home planet and they fight
against free Frieza and there's like
there's a bomb that takes like now there
is it's like the bomb says like oh
there's three minutes left until
activation on the bomb and that three
minutes took like 15 episodes I was like
ding Wow
you know that's that's pretty cool it's
back in the day back in the day in a
blitz game anybody can drop anything a
detail yep yep you know do to to to
grant
I mean to grandmasters everybody drops a
few pieces if you're not on you know so
15 rating points if we can now if we can
win games after that I will take that
I'll take that oh so you know how you
know how you said anybody under 2,000 as
an amateur so this guy's technically
you're an amateur right now mister 1985
big day ago he's is admitting it agreed
great now you're gonna fight back on
that one yeah we just don't don't pound
it pander to the to the trolls okay
technically you're okay Danny I need you
to I'm gonna do this and I need you to
shoot a energy beam from my hands do it
I don't see it
you're killing me Danny it was there
there I
yeah we're gaining we're gaining the -
where were you having we're yeah we're
you up in this game are you up in this
game I haven't pay attention I'm not
getting checked on see oh no no no not
at all not at all
one sec Wow just keep on attacking that
kingside there you go I didn't drop
nothing
better not drop anything what I wanted
to start a new nickname for you mr.
dropper that's not good we need
something better there we go here we go
oh the old the joke you started the
street oh he's talking to himself now
which means he is thinking hard
here comes rook takes h7 Queen takes g6
3/7 Mabel is pre-pre calling it pretty
common I see if it happens
come on all right here we go nobody's
got this inner me so check I don't care
about that little inner Me's oh okay
about that I care thank you now wouldn't
you just yeah there and then they take
and then I play rook to d1 oh man I'm in
a lot of trouble now looks like your
pre-pre calling that those moves then
didn't happen did it come on Mike hack
this system hack the system win this bar
sir oh yes you are very late if you do
it's just joining us now we're about to
end the show what else did I have here
and then we do it again alright I'm
listening to Dennis so if I don't win
it's all on benefit wow just basically
basically it's just putting all putting
it all on Dennis day even though he
doesn't even have the game in front of
him you know
baris all we are everybody is glad
you're here but next time when you get
in earlier so you can challenge this to
a game and Michael happily beat you I
don't know if that's gonna happen just
saying it's stuff
what is Mike's feed a yellow he does not
have a feed a rating but as you